[Musik]
das ist kein rennwagen sondern eine
mülltonne auf der startbahn des locker
flughafens erlitten hat der engländer
andrew jennings einen neuen guinness
weltrekord aufgestellt
mit dieser mülltonne hier hat der
ingenieur umgebaut will raus und
motorradmotor einig verrückte idee kommt
andy bei einem traurigen erlebnisse im
juni verstärkt sein bester freund und in
gedenken plant ende schließlich einen
weltrekord mit der motorisierten
mülltonne
das ziel für doré cordsen zunächst 48
kilometer pro stunde die mit der
mülltonne auf den asphalt gebracht
werden sollen
dann schießt die grünen rakete los und
es wird spannend
wenn du gegen die seiten des grünen
flitzers doch andy beißt die zähne
zusammen und schaltet mit vierten gang
und es werden unglaubliche 72 98
kilometer pro stunde
rekord der engländer sitzen der
schnellsten müttern und fährt mit einem
weltrekord nach hause wenn in zukunft
der milch schnell weg gebracht werden
muss könnte bei andy jennings das
telefon klingelt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schau dir
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren